congratulations
yes i'm going to ignore
13.
you'll have to use this though because
this isn't shaped
but you can go through it and shade it
the time being one o'clock i went to
call the committee of conference
on hp2 to order
we will continue where we were yesterday
we did
quite a bit of work thank you to
everybody and lba worked
all night trying to get us summaries so
we knew exactly where we were this
morning greatly appreciated
which is the second section concerning
the
sale of the lakes region facility we did
part of that yesterday
and the house will exceed to the senate
on that section
this morning we will move from there to
page 14.
we had some questions yesterday on
section 23
which is the bureau of adult and elderly
services
by holding it we had an opportunity to
get our questions answered
and the house will accede to section 23.
section 24 was similar it
is concerning the foster grandparent
program and again we had some questions
we took care of those and the house will
accede to the senate
on section 24. i'd like to move to page
and we have senate section 36
representative edwards i believe you
have an amendment i think
representative turcotte will yield his
seat to you
to if you want to have your amendment
passed out and discuss it
i believe senator bradley also has an
amendment
and we will discuss
senator bradley's amendment following
that on this same section if that's okay
representative edwards when you are
uh thank you madam chair um and for the
people at home
i i'd like to start out by saying
that i've been asked by 128
of our fellow house representatives to
um introduce this amendment um
what we're wanting to do is to drive
the financial and physical separation
of abortion services from the state
family planning money and in discussions
a week or two ago with senator bradley
it was our understanding or my
understanding rather
that the issue that the senate had
primarily with what we had
done in hb2 was that we didn't
do enough to ensure a graceful
transition
between the status quo and the future
state
of physical and financial separation so
senator um this this amendment is meant
to address what i thought i heard um
that day uh if you if you have it
do you see that sir okay okay so lines
uh one through two or one through five
is really just
statement of intent that we're we're
trying to achieve
physical and financial separation
and and then lines 6 through 15
are the language that talks about
which monies would still be permitted
despite this
bill and uh and it also
ends by talking about the physical and
financial separation of reproductive
health facilities from
our fam state family planning programs
uh lines 16 and 17
are really there to give a graceful
closure
to contracts by saying that any contract
that's in place
i want to say natural life but that
doesn't really fit i want that it wants
to go to
its term of contract
lines 18 through 21 are intended to
create a 10
000 incentive um for up to
seven clinics to have an incentive for
new awardees to come in and compete um
so we we do want competition we we have
heard
that in the past when these went up for
bid that there wasn't enough competition
so in order to get the competition we're
uh sweetening the pot with a ten
thousand dollar incentive
and then in the possibility
that there may not be
a new awardee in a particular area
then this bill would authorize the
extension for the current contract
awarder
awardee for up to three extensions
so we do not want to create
a lack of continuity of care and so
um we put all of this in effect on one
october
2021 so that uh dhhs has an opportunity
to put rfps together
and go get solicitations and do some
evaluations
so so so we've attempted to create a
graceful transition from where we're at
to
where 128 house republicans are asking
us to go
so if you're watching at home the house
had a position
it is not what you just heard but it was
similar and the senate had a position
they modified the house
representative edwards has gone over an
expanded
house position we thank him for that
it's my understanding senator bradley
that you have an amendment on this same
section
and if you are ready to discuss it at
this time we could have
lba pass that out all right thank you
very much madam chair it's amendment
1929 okay if you're at home 2021-1929-h
is what we're going to be looking at
so thank you madam chair this takes a um
somewhat different approach than my
friend
uh representative edwards and i would
say this i appreciate the
um willingness to try to make sure that
reproductive health care services
separate from abortion
force can continue to be
provided for low-income women i think we
would all agree or i hope we would that
that's
important um to make sure that those
services
are available to people but at the same
time
i think many of us believe
that there should not be public funding
uh
for the provision of an actual abortion
so we build upon the language that was
in the senate bill
starting i believe it's on line seven
of amendment 1929 that says
every family planning project will
contain
the following provisions number one
no funds to subsidize abortion directly
or indirectly
two that there will be um
any an inspection either by the
department or a delegated agent to
inspect the financial records of family
planning project
to monitor compliance with us so those
are things that
i believe are being done now so this is
not new and different
but it goes on to say that at the end of
each fiscal year the commissioner shall
certify in writing
to the governor and council that they
have
either themselves or through a
designated agent reviewed the
expenditure of funds
and they certify that no state funds
awarded
by the department could be used to
actually provide
abortion services and if the
for commissioner fails to make such
a certification
then the governor and council based on
that evidence
would find that abortion services have
been provided with the funds then there
is a choice for the provider
they're either in breach and this is a
on line 18
in breach of the terms of the contract
or
b they would have to suspend all
operations
at that point until they were
physically and financially separate so
basically what it's saying is
if this inspection reveals there's
commingling of funds for the provision
of abortion services
at that point in time either
the grant would be suspended or the
physical separation would occur
and i think that that is a better way to
make sure
that um these funds are not co-mingled
i do recall it was probably in the
[Music]
budget that we had it wasn't in the
budget was a separate bill the same
discussion about the provision of these
services
at the time i think i received four
very comprehensive letters from then
commissioner tumpus
that basically were certifying at that
point in time that funds were not being
commingled
um i hope that is still the case this is
one of those
trust but verify moments and if
it's not verified then the consequences
that
i think you representative edwards led
on in the house
would take effect but before that the
provision
hopefully of these services could go
unimpeded and a clear recognition
by any provider they would know that if
there was a co-mingling
at that point in time the separation
would occur or the program suspended
so thank you madam chair questions or
comments
representative edwards has your hand up
i i do have a question for the senator
senator first thank you very much
for
thank thank you very much for including
the the term physically and financially
separate in your language i think that's
a a recognition of of what's really
important
i don't know if i'm leading as much as
i'm listening to 128
people who are very passionate about
this and one of the beliefs
is that no audit will ever be able to
reveal
the extent to which the money is
fungible
and the money going in to help one side
of the
clinic isn't it's just no way to keep
that money from
helping the other side um but i do
appreciate
um your language in here i i just wonder
you come very close
to the word audit and and don't use the
word audit i'm just curious what you're
thinking on that yes sir
well i i think certainly the way that
this is written
inspect the financial records that could
be an audit
it would be at the discretion obviously
of whoever the commissioner was
but um and where it says
um his or her designated agent or
delegate again that could well be an
auditor
a follow-up thank you man i'm sure um
so so i i've been requested to
try to make sure that any audit or any
investigation that's done
is something that could be publicly
shared on a website do you have any
thoughts about that sir
i would believe
based on my understanding of the right
to know law
and how we work here that the department
would be under an obligation to reveal
because it would have to go to the
governor council the
um findings of whatever
inspection audit whatever we want to
call it
but that's my belief but i do
i mean i do believe that that would be
required
for either a or b
to go into effect it has to go to the
governor council
so i think it would be a fully public
process
aren't those documents to the governor
and council now available online
for every meeting i believe they are i
believe that's the case
that's what i thought that's all of my
questions
senator bradley moves amendment
2021-1929-s and i think
senator rosenwald is your hand up to
second
okay let me see if i can get a second
senator morris
recognized
one is that state funds
are not used to take proportions
and that means that the patient
so generally i think as a legislature
we believe that the legislature should
not
meddle in the affairs of private
organizations so i'm wondering
because that looks like a departure from
that but i
also questioned
the language online where he
i'm wondering if there are other
examples
of the state telling medical providers
to suspend their operations when their
license and their scope of practice
allows them to
deliver that care of that people
sandra bradley can you answer those well
i'll do my best i mean i think that this
language is consistent with the hyde
amendment
which has long been the law of the land
for federal funding
that there should not be public dollars
federally used for the provision of
abortion services so i would agree with
my
normally i don't think government gets
in between
these services but we do have a federal
law
we have long had a state prohibition
that's usually been
re-upped in every succeeding trailer
bill
of one kind or another that prohibits
and that's consistent with
the hyde amendment so
while it it would not be
treated the same as say a cancer
screening
um or treatment or something like that i
agree with you
but we have a in this country
under the hyde amendment and you know
new hampshire's adoption of the hyde
amendment
um specific prohibitions on
the use of public funding for abortion
so i think that it's
um while it's a different category it's
appropriate
because you have these family planning
dollars
that have that prohibition on it both in
federal and
do you have a follow-up representative
rosenwald thank you i'm sorry senator
roosevelt
cindy and i served together on house
finance and i know
she's moved on to the senate and
sometimes my brain knows that sometimes
it doesn't
that's okay i was just wondering if you
could respond to my second question
i think i could repeat it yes so you
said that
b would direct um
the private medical providers to suspend
all operations and i'm wondering
what other examples the state has done
that
when they're practicing medical care
that is
within their license and their scope of
practice
well i think i just gave a
probably a rather long explanation of
the hyde amendment
and new hampshire's efforts so obviously
um
if there is a prohibition on
use of these funds for abortion
the provision of abortion this
if somebody violated that law this is a
penalty for violating
that law in fact it's just following
funds forward
so you'd be expanding
the cease and desist beyond
stop providing abortions with state
money
which they don't do to suspend
all operations cancer screenings
pap smears breast exams
uh routine primary care you would be
telling a licensed medical provider to
stop practicing medicine if they were
utilizing
yes if they were utilizing
the dollars that are in the family
planning contract for the provision of
abortion
which they're not supposed to do and i
would agree with you
i don't believe it happens in new
hampshire so this is
as much as anything an insurance policy
to ensure that it doesn't happen
i agree i don't believe it is happening
based on
the research that i did in 2011 now
that was 10 years ago but i think it's
still the same that being said
there are a number of questions that
people raise
and if there was a violation of that
then
um there has to be some consequence and
that's what
um this calls for as opposed to
the house language that would require
the separation immediately
and and that could lead as we found
um several years ago when i think
governor sununu put out
the family contracts for bid and there
were no bidders
um that would lead to a an immediate
cessation of those services which
you and i would not want i think
representative edwards has a question
uh thank you madam chair i i just uh for
people who are watching this i i just
think
something's really important to keep in
mind that we're talking about
state money that's going to family
planning services
and the house has shown strong support
for the family planning program
three years ago the funding level was at
000 we've raised it 10 percent each year
to this year where we've accepted the
governor's proposal of 812
000 so so we are fully in support
of having a very strong family planning
program
that's well resourced and is protected
so that it's
continuous and it can provide service to
everyone who needs it regardless of
income
so so there is absolutely no dispute
about that
all all we're trying to do is to make
sure that when people go into a family
planning clinic
that they're going in there to plan a
family and not to be seeking an abortion
or to have the hidden indicators of
the clinic or the room across the
hallway
being used to provide those abortions
just trying to keep
family planning separate from
the constitutionally protected right
women have to an abortion but just keep
senator rosenwald thank you i would just
comment that i think this amendment goes
way beyond that
by allowing the state to
essentially hold health care
hostage for up to 15 000 people
if by some
stroke of lba's pen or whoever's doing
the audit
some state funds were
shown to be going to an abortion
which doesn't happen that would suspend
possibly all operations
including things that are not abortion
related and i fear
that some patients
might develop cancer and that would be
on us
i am not i can't go there but thank you
representative
judging from some of the correspondence
we've had saying
don't stop abortions don't prevent me
from getting an abortion
we are here doing a budget we are
determining how
federal house how state monies get spent
how the taxpayers monies get spent
that's our responsibility
and this state has decided they do not
want to spend money for abortions
we're not stopping abortions we're just
stopping funding of them i want to make
that point
very clear thank you representative
weiler okay on the motion to adopt
amendment 2021-1929-s
if the house is in favor of adoption
senator morse science
the motion passes seven to one
with one senator opposed
thank you both gentlemen that was very
nice of you
this point of order man uh what do we do
with uh
my amendment do we just let it die thank
you for the clarification
i would like to say that we propose to
make it a house bill next year
excellent thank you
the next section we have not agreed on
is found on page 51 and it was actually
a house section that
the senate did not move on it was at the
house section 58
however yesterday we agreed with the
senate
on language that would not only resolve
this problem for doc
but for every agency so the house is in
total agreement of
getting rid of this section mr cain
and i think we were just on the topic of
audits
don't i have an amendment for an audit
based on
a fund in das sure we have
an amendment for a comprehensive review
of the medical trust
subsidy which we can hand out if you'd
now
this is amendment 2021-1967-h
it actually relates to work we did
yesterday on sections 14 and 15
that we either agreed with and or
amended
and this will have the office of the
legislative budget assistant conducting
a comprehensive review
of the medical insurance subsidy trust
account
including but not limited to the
transfer funds to and from the new
hampshire retirement system
and the state and other former employees
rate setting trust account record
keeping and reporting
this is in compliance with state and
federal legislation and
other relevant factors as determined by
the lba
the reason we have that is that we have
two
sections concerning this medical
insurance subsidy trust
that while we're working on it we also
think it is time to have a complete stop
and do a review and make sure that
everybody is being protected we are
senator bradley uh question so will this
replace section 14 and 15.
no sir it is in addition we agreed with
14 in the amendment yesterday so this is
a new section
right that relates to would you like a
motion i would love a
motion i'll move on to pass thank you
senator rosenwald seconds if the house
is in favor of adopting 2021-19678
please raise your hand we are unanimous
senator moores senator
okay that's unanimous mike we're on
page six in our side-by-side comparison
of highlights i think
yesterday the house intended
on page 98 to agree
that we were no longer needed house
section 141 i'm afraid i wasn't very
clear on that
the reason we agreed to that is that
money has been paid by arpa funds
so correct my apologies for not being
clear that's okay we just wanted to make
sure
all right and now we have page 99
we have sections 147 and 148
body worn cameras for the department of
corrections
this goes along with an amendment that
senator bradley brought in towards the
end of the day relating to senate bill
and based on that the house is now ready
to exceed to this section
on page 103 representative umberger has
an amendment she would like to discuss
with us
if that could be passed out for her
karen i don't know the number i'm sorry
representative please let us know what's
going on with mimit2021-1952h
uh thank you madam chairman uh
what uh what this amendment does is
uh change the date
of um higher to
30 june 2023
on the position in
the department of justice does this
relate to something
division two had a new program and
did police training standards start
something that relates to this
uh yes but that was funded in hb1
yes but it's relative to that to give
them time to get where they need to be
is that
that's correct okay comments or
questions
senator bradley so this was a request of
doj and
police standards and training to move it
back six months
no
i think and probably not i don't know
representative berger explained it to
the house this way
that because there was a new program in
police training standards she felt that
they should have time to work on it come
together
and work with doj on the needs and that
this was a little
early not giving them time to make that
decision
and represent ambergris i have
misrepresented what you said to me
please correct me no that's correct
i'll move the amendment senator bradley
moves the adoption of 2021-1952h
represent umberger seconds
if the house is in favor of this
adoption please raise your hand
we are four opposed four to one
six to two and then the amendment is
adopted
all right
page seven mike i have a question for
you on this next one we're on page
137 um section 190
three yeah we need an adoption
a motion i'm sorry an amendment for this
or is this something that we normally
would
move that lba does technical and
maintenance corrections that you would
correct
what is the best way to proceed with
this section so
for on page 137 of the side by side
senate section 193 you remember the
discussion
uh the department of energy whereas the
commissioner appointing the commissioner
yes
so the committee made a motion to remove
the commissioner
uh the establishment of that
commissioner position is necessary in
statute so we do need an amendment which
we can hand out
in addition we do outline we use the
governor's language fulfilling those
positions which is actually outlined in
the department of energy amendment so
some positions are appointed by governor
and council
some are purely by commissioner but we
make a reference to that
so if we can hand that amendment out
relative to that please do it will you
also make sure the governor's budget
director has a copy of this
matt while you weren't here yesterday we
discovered that the commissioner of the
department of energy was going to
appoint
the commissioner of department of energy
work
is that on there you go i would agree
that wouldn't work thanks uh and i did
see that conversation yesterday
so i'm glad we're fixing it today
and i have a motion to adopt amendment
2021-1955-h
represent weiler moves
senator bradley seconds if the house is
in favor of this
adoption please raise your hand
and flipping our page
this is another one where i'm not
certain
that we actually took action but
intended to we just passed by
this is section 158 and i can tell you
what happened
in section 158 what the house had
i mean page 158 section 227
what the house had was change the
membership of the site evaluation
committee because the governor had asked
originally to appoint the commissioner
of the department of energy to the site
evaluation committee
however with that appointment that
committee now had an even number
and the house was afraid with a
committee with an even number
would consistently vote eight to eight
with no way to
break the tie so we had made one minor
change in order to
accommodate the adding the addition of
the commissioner of the department of
energy
i think the governor and his staff and
man i'm going to ask you
for sure but i believe the decision was
to leave the site evaluation committee
as it was without the addition of the
department
of commission commissioner of department
of energy on it
is that correct ma'am that's correct and
the thinking there was osi did not
sit on that committee there was no need
for the department
of energy's commissioners so the house
is succeeding to
the house had no comparable section
and i'm again going to ask matt now that
he's here
we held on to that i assume this is
something that came up after this pass
the house because i know everybody was
working on this
correct we think there are a lot of
conversations that are worth
while having on the site evaluation
committee those are best done outside
the budget
at the request of uh leadership
of science technology and energy this
commission has a very aggressive
deadline
i believe with their recommendations due
october 1st of this year
so certainly in the intent is to clean
up the site evaluation committee with
any necessary changes
in the next session thank you the house
will exceed to the senate position
mr kane on page 168 section 240 do we
we do there was an amendment handed out
yesterday uh
by representative ober and then senator
bradley had us drafted an amendment
which we'll hand out now
which addresses that i hope
2021-1951s
um line one talks about
non-lapsing special fund sorry line
three
line four says it will be continually
appropriated to the commission to be
expended in accordance with this section
provided that at the start of the period
in which there is no adopted state
operating budget which we hope happens
very rarely
the commission shall in a timely manner
seek the approval of the fiscal
committee of the general court
to continue using monies from the
renewable energy fund
to support renewable energy rebate and
grant programs
in order to ensure that there are no
interruptions in the programs
i'm good senator bradley moves amendment
2021-1951
s represent wyler's seconds
the house is in favor please raise your
hand
all righty
all right and i think there's another
one we kind of held till matt came back
matt's so glad he came back matt we're
on page 177
um the house
senate section 251 the house did not
have the repeal
of rsa 374-f cohen four
could you just talk to us a little bit
about that sure so
roman one in house section 242
was determined that it should stay so
there's no repeal there's no
reenactment that lie will just stay on
the books
roman 2 in house section 242
is the same as what you see in roman 1
and section
251 of the senate version roman 2 in the
senate version
is new and i would say there's plenty of
other statutes
in the energy law that could be cleaned
up in a subsequent bill next section
our next session this was a one-time
requirement from 1997
for restructuring to have the utilities
file
a single report one time that's still on
the books today and it made sense to
clean it up here
okay in that case the house is going to
we're going to turn to page 199.
i think we needed some details on this
but i can't remember exactly where we
were
we are looking at section 272
we would like some details the house had
no comparable section here
sure this is another area of the law
that is from
the way the energy sector worked prior
to restructuring
i believe these lots have been in the
book since the 50s and have not been
used since that time
and in the restructured wholesale market
that
new hampshire operates under iceland new
england there's no real
mechanism for these sections of law to
become operable
and given that they haven't been used in
my lifetime
much less other people's lifetimes again
made sense to clean that up here
okay we're okay with that right
all right the house succeeds to the
we are on page 230
the house had asked to retain
the single sales factor
of the business profits tax chairman
major of the house ways and means
committee
wanted to do some research into that
he has done that and i think i'm
repeating this correctly
represent major the house will now
accede to the senate's position and
yes
welcome and that is
i think my
sections to a page
230 and again 234 there's a committee
that we don't need
because we're not doing this yes to page
236 has enactment of the single sales
factor
and page 236 has a repeal of a
legislative committee
so all of those are included in that
that's correct sections 287 and 290
okay on
which is the page 243 and the compare
report
and these were house sections 303
this relates to a bill
that has been retained in the house
and the house position is we will agree
to remove these from hb2 and in the fall
we will work on our retained bill
so we are can mike
mark all of those off yes section 303
through
section 321.9 we'll put as uh
senate seating sorry how succeeding to
the senate yes
uh we're going to skip to page 11 i
think
nope we didn't have any disagreement
there we're going to go to
page 12.
this is the sununu youth center
i think we have an amendment and i
believe we would like to have a
discussion with the senate i'm not sure
if you've seen the amendment i know i
haven't seen it
representative turkan would you yield to
representative edwards thank you sir
you're very
and can we have the amendment passed out
the amendment is uh currently at ols
being redrafted so it's not available at
this time oops
okay we are currently going to hold on
that
until we have the amendment so we will
move on but why
represent edwards is here if i could
just point out on page 273
senate section 325 was on hold and that
has to do with child care services
okay let's do that one thank you mike
jeff sorry i didn't know that amendment
okay we're going to turn to page 273 if
you're chugging along with us at home
and we're looking at senate pass section
representative edwards would you like to
this is department of health yes ma'am
no i i know i'm just uh
trying to get my my eyes and thinking uh
aligned
child care services i was trying to talk
no i gotta
fill the dead air so um
we believe that this would have been
better going through a policy committee
than
they come into the finance committee
directly in the hb2 process
but um as it stands uh
we are willing to proceed to the senate
position
okay
the house will exceed to the senate
position
and we still don't have the sununu
center because so we will
move on i'm sorry can i have a
a second shot at this i i had my book
upside down
and i read the wrong thing we are not
exceeding to this
to the center position we're having a
second shot try to
thank you so much the book is written
where you have to go back and forth and
i just made a mistake i apologize
the book did not for people who are at
home or
in the audience the book did not get
printed so like a page where you turn it
up and you read the next one
so you have to pick up your book and you
have to switch it because the print's
upside down
said remorse i think we informed advent
services we're not paying for the books
so but we're getting so much exercise
out of it it's good for our weight
program
all right so so the essence of the
of the senate position in um section 357
is that they uh show a preference for
we're on section 325
i am on that number it is 325. thank you
uh and it's um a preference for
attendance-based payment
for child care is that right
good uh so um the the current
the status quo now is that uh payments
are
are made on uh on an attendance basis
um and not an enrollment basis
and so rather than moving to an
enrollment basis in hb2
we'd like to put this into a house bill
and have the policy committee look at it
next
year in talking with the department
this morning and last night they would
need
time to make plans to
to support a policy shift from
attendance
to enrollment they would need new rules
and procedures
they would have some issues with their
i.t system only being able to access one
source of funds and
not multiple for different things so
what
what i have agreed to with the
department is that i would recommend
that we take this section
roll it into a house bill let a policy
committee look at it
um the the it reprogramming alone could
take
many many months so so that's that's
what i would
ask us to do so it is your position
if i could to leave this on hold we do
not have an amendment to delete this
section we would just leave it on hold
and it would be addressed in the bill is
that where we are
comments senator bradley so would it be
possible to ask representative walner a
question
absolutely um
thank you representative walner and i
had a um
brief conversation in the hall before we
got here i just wanted to confirm that
you are in support
of representative edward's position that
this would be better deleted from hb2
we can hear you but nobody else can hear
you
thank you um there are a couple of
things about this that concern me
about um the way the enrollment based
amen
part of the amendment is written and the
one
most concerning is that we can use no
state general funds
and i think that will be very
problematic for the department
and for child care providers because the
reason
there are general funds in the state
budget
are for the payment to providers for the
provision of child care
so if we're no longer able to use those
we will not spend down our general funds
and i think that will
um be problematic for us present in the
next year
but also into the future
and so if i could please so you're in
agreement with representative edwards
that this needs a
separate bill that goes through the
policy committees in both the house and
senate next year
yes and i think that the senate may
actually
have an enrollment-based bill
in your we do that we re-referred that
you re-referred
so there is already a bill that could be
um used in january
you're correct in that thank you senator
rosenwald
oops i'm sorry senator bradley follow up
could i ask
a question of representatives you could
okay
i just want to be clear you're not
recommending we take the house
version out just the
senate's edition just
the senate edition the house the house
piece was
in there in both the house and the
senate um
i'm just suggesting that we take out the
um what the senate added
thank you could we identify those
because we need to yeah sure on page
274 uh you'll see highlighted
at the top of the page where it begins
the department shall provide
enrollment based reimbursement uh rep
representative wallner is stating
that um not to agree with that language
so it would be basically
the senator seating to the house if the
senate agrees
okay the senate will see to the house's
position on this section and
we will still have it marked as done
uh we're going to hold on let's see
all right yesterday we had held page 315
section 384
section because representative umberger
wanted to talk to senator
hennessey who had originated this
language
representative omburger where are we
with this
now i am fine with this uh
amendment the senate amendment so i
would recommend that we a seat
okay so the house will accede to the
senate
on section 384 on page 3
15. if the house members are in favor
oh well we don't have to do that we're
just that wasn't emotion we exceed
we're done duh there just
isn't enough wine to keep my brain going
all right representative edwards
on page 319 we had held
i think at your request
when
so thank you madam chair i apologize for
the delay there
but uh we're on page 319 and it runs on
to 320
sections 399 and 400 on the senate
and um essentially um
what the senate is requesting is um
a report with some very specific
things in it related to
[Music]
child behavioral health and
while i think we can accede to this i
just want to point out
that there's some risk that this report
will be a little bit redundant with what
is
being done by the state health
assessment commission
and their publication of a state health
improvement or implementation plan
there could be a little redundancy i
hopefully the commissioners
will coordinate so that we don't have
two conflicting reports
and then the other item is uh item eight
i'd want to point out where it deals
with
plans to develop and or coordinate a
cross
system assessment tool and it goes on
from there
um i uh am concerned that we're
reaching out to a population that's
beyond the medicaid population
to the general population and that we're
collecting
a lot of data and i'm concerned that
dhhs
doesn't have the necessary
[Music]
privacy and security protections uh in
place to be
uh bringing in all this data and doing
the analysis so
so i will just say that as a long-term
concern
but other than that i i do believe the
house
all right so we will the house will
accede to sections
399 and 400
and just that brings us to sections
401 and 402
on page 321 which
we can accede to this system of care has
been
under a great deal of discussion and for
years i think senator bradley has been
pivotal in all that so i i believe we
can see
the house will exceed to the senate
on sections 401 and 402
yesterday we held 403
and 404 there were a couple of sections
that mr ripple looked at for us we had
a couple of concerns we have an hb1
limited hhs to a maximum of 3 000
employees
and i've forgotten the other section mr
ripple you will remember why we wanted
to do that and you researched it can you
tell us where we are
uh yes there was also another section in
house bill 2
that related to uh abolishing positions
that had been vacant since
july 1 2018 so that would not apply in
this case
okay so we know that in these two
sections
the abolishment does not apply and the
limit
that represent edwards and his team put
in
does apply so are we at this point mr
uh representative edwards ready to
accede to the senate
uh yes madam chair uh this is very
similar to
a section that we dealt with earlier
dealing with the cp
ws positions and so both this and the
contracting sections are
fine because they uh have to be managed
return the page we're on page 14. we're
on page
section 408 and it doesn't matter what
way i want to go my book's always upside
down in the wrong
way
which even when i turn the page it's
upside down
i could but my notes are in here i just
want to thank lba for my new book
yeah thank you very much i have a new
book as well but my notes are in the
old book which i didn't have time to
transfer to the new book
so all right we are
at section 408 section 408 is a
prospective repeal regarding eligibility
for services
extended representative edwards we held
this at your request
yes ma'am when division 3 saw this
it seemed like a ongoing issue where it
was just in every budget cycle so we
deleted it what we have since found
out is that 10 years ago this
allowed our child care providers
to go ahead and start to maintain wait
lists if we didn't have this section in
there that would have technically been
an illegal act
and so we have continued to put this in
every two years to
protect them and allow them to keep such
a list so
at this point we should accept this
language
and i would like us to do a simple bill
in january just so we don't have to do
this every budget cycle
all right the house will exceed to the
senate
and maybe in the future we won't be
doing this
we have three sections on hold
starts on page 328 sections 427 to 429
and this looks like a fairly simple
situation
and we're gonna toss a million dollars
at
it so you say to yourself well what's a
million dollars when you're working with
these i mean
the amount of money we deal with just
boggles the mind
however the house had not had
a bill on this this had been a senate
bill that had then been put on the table
did not come to the house
so we were doing some research
mr cain really did some digging in this
morning
and we discovered that for this benefit
there are 85 700
individuals eligible for this benefit
medicaid allows one thousand five
hundred dollars
per person for the amount of the service
that you can receive
in a year some of that is a federal
share
unfortunately some of that is a state
and when the senate was looking at this
the state share was
around seven million dollars
i had a note from mr kane
after that that already the medium range
of the cost had risen to 7.45 million
however the high range that we could
expect this to be on a yearly basis
is 11.06 million
this section i provided only three
months of benefit
but would greatly impact
legislatures going forward
did not have a hearing public hearing in
the house
did not get seen by house hhs
did not get referred to house finance
division three as a second committee to
dig into the funds
so the house is going to continue to
hold on these sections
well we think it's a good benefit when
you look at
committing somebody to pay 11 million
dollars
when you haven't dug into all the
details
it's very difficult so we're continuing
to work
but we are not going to be at this time
able to move forward on that section
that brings us to
page 332
i skipped one i certainly did and i
apologize
my apologies to the senators and
representative edwards who was about to
leave his seat
uh we're on page 331
where people have it one way and we're
sections 433 and 434
and i think we were going to ask lba
if he could if they could dig into some
sections representative edwards says i
understand this
we just don't have any details how this
would be sent
etc do you want to talk about that uh
thank you madam chair uh i've i've had
an opportunity
since uh this morning's meeting with you
to speak with the governor's
team and and while the governor's team
still supports this 1.5 million
i i think there's no argument to the
idea that
this is a fairly small amount of money
without a particularly well-defined
statement of scope of what we would be
going out to buy
the senior centers there's approximately
800 of them in the state that could
potentially compete for one and a half
million dollars
and so this this program has sort of the
look and feel of something that had a
good intent but uh isn't set up for
success
and i i would i would ask us to hold it
and if we wanted to bring it back
does the senate wish to speak
i mean again this is part of our ongoing
efforts to
try to deal with mental health um
obviously it targets seniors
um so that's why the senate
you know voted for this and i think
there was a corresponding
uh 1.5 million dollar appropriation that
i believe
we've acceded to um
for veterans so it's in the same
mental health problems that we're trying
to
resolve we um you're correct
we did agree yesterday you had the 1.5
million for the veterans we had some
language that went together we merged
them together
and we voted the new amendment in
yesterday
so you're correct senator rosenwald did
i see you put your hand up
yes thank you madam chair the senate
worked with the
advocates for seniors on this language
this was an item they had worked with
the governor's office on
and they came to us and we agreed to
narrow the scope
of what the appropriation could be used
for
in the budget it's introduced it could
be also
used for capital projects
and we didn't think there was enough
money for that so
we limited the scope but found that
senior seniors in new hampshire were
particularly isolated and we were
concerned about their
access to programs that would benefit
their mental health
outside of uh traditional
please so i i agree
and embrace the concern about our senior
citizens uh mental health after this
long pandemic and
long periods of uh of imposed isolation
i um i i think the issue remains that
it's only a million and a half dollars
to be spread around
uh 800 senior centers
and uh the scope on this
in the bill simply says supporting
services to combat struggles with mental
health and social isolation
and so that's not a a particularly
identifiable scope of work i don't know
how we could effectively issue rfps and
do the contracting
that would deliver something of value
and
and and while i agree that we have a
problem i
i'd like to see this cooked a little bit
more
i may be wrong but uh we've already
accepted
house bill 1 i believe the increase to
the
senior centers in the state of new
hampshire in there
but they get paid i think that message
should be pretty loud and clear having
served in the 90s as a
president of these one of these boards
they're not making money
um i can assure you of that
if this needs to be fixed then you're
willing to work with the senate in
january to come up with something
um you know i can tell you the rainy day
fund's
climbing up to 165 million just with a
few actions we've taken
and the um i i think there's going to be
revenues left over from this year beyond
that
that we should do something to help
these groups
i'd be willing to file legislation with
you to do
something and define it better because
our discussions in the senate we
realized there wasn't enough money to do
it would be an honor and i would pull in
uh the chair of hhs
pearson who'd love to work on this as
well so
thank you for the officer so does that
proposal senator morris i'm not sure
you're
proposing something in addition and
still keeping this or you're proposing
something instead of this
if i could get the senate to vote with
me i'd say
to the house but i'm not sure i'll move
the
seat to the house okay
the senate will accede to the house
and then senator roosevelt thank you for
not
objecting
okay that brings us now where i was
trying to go before when i was jumping
the gun a little bit
to page 332
where i think it was senator gaida
put in a motion an amendment
to lower the license fees
by almost all the money for keno
the house hasn't had a bill on this i
don't know did you guys have a bill or
did this just come in
what this lowers keno licenses to a
hundred dollars in
sooner morse i think it may be more
effective to discuss
the next item first okay
um which is senator geider also
opportunity i believe in keem
to give them the opportunity to get
historical racing
i think the senate might look favorably
on the item before that to the house's
position
if we could give this one group the
opportunity to get in
i know everyone wants to expand it
everywhere else
um that's not the bill that came before
the house or the senate
the villa came for the house and the
senate said let's do it for a period of
a couple of years
and then we'll look to open it up to the
whole state of new hampshire
that's not what we're discussing we're
discussing the opportunity of
one company that started at a certain
point in time
they have to apply for this and they
have a little bit of a hurdle to get
there but
um i i think we could give them that
opportunity
um along with the fact that we just
passed the bill so
if we could do that then we could talk
about the one before
representative turcotte i believe you
did the research into
the section on perry mutual pools we're
looking at section 440 sir
uh i did some research on on it issue
that i was not really
that familiar with in speaking to a
couple individuals
it appears the only change would be to
the house bill that we passed and that
was signed by the governor would be to
change the date
uh the purpose of the original date was
to
uh establish a certain number of
uh locations as
it were the ones that were in effect and
in speaking with a a few individuals on
this particular
amendment change it was highly
recommended that
we remain uh with the existing language
and and the date
i know the senator just referenced an
individual or a location in keene and
that was actually part of the
discussion i had so i i would be opposed
to
actually either either the two thank you
let's just hold on to these for a little
that is going to bring us
okay well yesterday we had an
interesting situation on page 346
first the house held it then we
discovered we had voted
in favor of this so we said go ahead
but there was a question about whether
the governor had
signed the bill whether this should be
in both the bill and
in here and then the senate said to hold
mr cain do you have any idea where we
are
with page 346 at this time that's still
on hold i don't believe
correct me if i'm wrong that the
governor has signed with the bill yet
relative to the title behavioral in the
woodville fire district but
he has not signed it so right now that
section remains on hold
so yesterday we were trying to decide if
we needed it at all
or if we could just get an amendment to
delete it given it had been passed and
was
i think in enrolled bills do we have any
idea
okay i'm not sure it's going to happen
madam chair because
i haven't signed this yet uh-huh so this
hasn't even gotten to the senate
president yet i don't think it's gotten
to the speaker quite honestly
well i don't think it can get to him if
it hasn't gotten to you but
well it's the other way around because
this was a senate bill
um
the senate is the one who's the last put
to put it on hold still my point is
the day's up on thursday at 3 o'clock
it's not going to get stuck up in his
is there any reason we can't put it in
the budget
we had agreed yesterday after i found
out that we had
gentlemen shall we do that because we
did vote for his house position to pass
this
is it exactly the same as the bill we
passed
yes
we will the house will exceed let's get
this
we're having lots of conversation about
sections 4 51 which starts at the bottom
of 348 through 340
through 460 micro enterprise relief fund
save our granite stages fund mr kane can
sure i believe this remember where we
were yesterday uh the item remains on
hold it was
in senate bill 132 which passed the
senate hat
was laid on the table so the house has
and if i recall correctly this is only
to be funded with federal funds
that's correct only to be funded with
yeah could correspond burger
yeah we i was very confused about the
one dollar
i mean it says so mr kane can you walk
us through
section 452 which is where we see this
confusing dollar in three different
lines
yes a placeholder in section 352
um so one dollar of any federal funds
received by the state in response to
covet will be deposited into the fund
and at no
time shall the available balance i read
that as available balance of the fund
exceed one dollar in any fiscal year
um and then there's a free i don't find
that confusing
um it's there won't be a dollar in there
and it won't exceed a dollar that could
that won't buy me a glass of wine to get
through this
might buy a bottle of water though which
is
um i think the if i recall correctly
the maybe senator daniels can chime in
here but um
this was a placeholder for potential use
of
our funds um so
but do we shoot ourselves in the foot if
we say the fun
shall never be more than a dollar i'm
agreeing with you
i you don't know that that was the
intent
i think the intent the intent was to
mr cain would it be possible
to get an amendment from the lba
to keep put a dollar in
and keep the account open to receive
federal funds which i think is what we
sure and so what you'll see is a few
changes to the reference to a dollar as
a placeholder we'll just ensure that the
when that dollar is used it's to open
that account only
and then we'll make sure it's limited to
the federal funds so we can draft that
amendment
who would like to be the sponsor i will
i will
do that yes absolutely uh
before he we sent him off is there
anything else
in this section that you guys
have an issue with before we move on to
sections not dealing with this so let's
cena i don't see any but mr cain if
you and your staff see something will
you please take care of it so we have a
good amendment
tomorrow yes and i think you'll see it
again in section 457 the dollar
placeholder for the save our granted
stages fund we'll just make sure that um
it does not restrict that fund to only a
dollar okay
461 which is
an amendment that we talked about
yesterday
this is adding additional service
additional staff in the child protective
service
area of dcyf and i think we're all aware
if you read the newspaper watch the news
you are aware that we have had
some fairly significant issues and we're
all worried about
keeping our children as safe as possible
and especially children that get
put in the state care and are no longer
with their parents
and so yesterday we were asking the same
questions
about does this apply to the 3000
employee limit that is in hb1 mr ripple
i believe you have confirmed
to us that that 3 000 employee limit
applies here that's correct yes
okay thank you representative edwards
would you like to speak
at all in section 461 no ma'am i think
he said it all i i think we're prepared
to accede to the
senate language okay so the house will
exceed to the senate
462. i think we probably have some
questions we don't
really understand what we're doing there
representative edwards do you want to
speak to 462 that's also a
dhhs thank you thank you madam chair
um so um towards the
end of our hearings in division three
well we
were uh basically out of money with uh
what we had funded
and so when we received a list from dhhs
on things that they would like to have
that we had not funded this item
was on that list it went over to the
senate
um and so we we didn't we never
considered it in division three
so it's six hundred thousand dollars
each of
each fiscal year for 1.2 million total
it's intended to fund community
collaboration and parental assistance
programs
i i have to admit i don't know exactly
what that's going to do
but i'm i'm willing to uh trust the
the judgment and wisdom of the senate on
this um i'm i'm happy to accede to this
it would be nice to get an explanation
though my question
to represent edwards had been
we have a system of care we have as i
understand it 13 million dollars
that will non-lapse from this year that
will move forward into the next biennium
it's also my understanding that we put
27 million
in this next biennium's budget into the
system of care
which gives us a total of 40 million in
the system of care
and i wondered if any of that would be
used in
some of this or in collaborating with
this and again we don't really
understand this section so
if somebody could speak to that senator
roosevelt it looks like the ball fell in
your life i can speak to it
from a high level that would be better
than what we know thank you
so the these are programs that are
primary prevention um
to keep children and families out of
dcyf
this is not a division of behavioral
it also helps
grandparents who have custody
or are seeking custody of their
grandchildren
if the parents are unable to care for
them which we've seen
happening more often the community
collaboration was a competitive grant
that the state was awarded
and i don't know the amount offhand but
it also brings in
significant federal funds so it's really
more about
preventing dcyf involvement
okay thank you the house as
representative edwards said will accede
to the senate
on this section thank you mr cain do we
have any brand new amendments that we
haven't seen
related to other things i know there are
some amendments
that we have kind of on hold but there
may be
we had a couple of other amendments
and we also have while you're digging
through there
yesterday the house presented an
amendment
to the senate on the department of
military affairs to provide some
additional
funding for the civil air patrol that
was amendment 2021-1932h
as the senate thought about you ask us
to put on hold we did
a rare moment to the house oh in a rare
moment they will exceed to the house
i will say again if you were here
yesterday
much of the language in hb2 was exactly
the same between the house and senate
we worked together well but we also came
up independently with much of the same
language on many
issues
okay we have in front of us amendment
2021-1944-h
there was a bill i think it started in
the senate and it came to
the house about abolishing the gun line
which we both have passed
representative umberger did a great deal
of work
and is going to talk about this
thank you uh since
h or sb 141 and hb
334 have passed
the house and the senate they basically
end the gun line
we had added to the budget
three positions for safety
in order to improve the
gun line since
the other two bills have passed
uh we do not need these positions for
the gun line
however in that in
141 it also
said that safety would pay for
computer software and training for
the county sheriffs however there was no
money
actually appropriated and so
this also asked for the hundred thousand
dollars
for the counties and each county will
get
ten thousand dollars and we
it finalizes and the contingency down at
the bottom
because neither of these bills have been
signed that
if they don't become law
then we will not delete
the three positions from safety
where i this is what the legislature
question please uh representative
hamburger so uh just so i understand
that if
uh these three positions are not
necessary
if senate bill 141 were not enacted
i'll move me a moment second
senator bradley moves amendment the
adoption amendment 2021-1944-h
representative turcotte seconds the
house is in favor of adopting please
that hurts karen but we appreciate her
work on this she
she took one for the team on this the
senate
we are unanimous on this
we're going to take a break ladies and
gentlemen for 30 minutes
um it would be great if we had the
sununu
senator oel and i know you guys can't
hurry ols but in case it happens to be
ready it would be great if we had it
when we came back
so we will be in break for 30 minutes
thank you
mr speaker senator morrison jeb bradley
senator bill for using your office
are we live mr kane yes thank you
2021-1969-h
it's something that we looked at
yesterday wasn't quite right
senator bradley and i have been working
on senate bill 85
and the broadband matching grant
initiative and there was a change at the
okay mike if you could line three starts
with
nullification prior legislation and it
talks about
sb 85 if you could just help us
understand
exactly what's going on i know our
ultimate goal
was to keep sb 85 as it was however we
had
a change of having the broadband
initiative being run out of business and
economic affairs bea
instead of department of energy as sb 85
said
that's correct uh so lines three through
four and amendment 1969
h do nullify senate bill 85 of the 2021
legislative session that's it
um it's an exercise used by ols and used
by the legislature in the past instead
of
messing around with effective dates but
the language
of senate bill 85 is included with one
main change and that is on i believe
beginning on line
13 where instead of osi
it's in the department of business and
economic affairs
as a result you'll see on row 16 it's
under
rsa-120 the broadband matching grant
initiative is established
in all references to strategic
initiatives
should have been removed and replaced
senator bradley um could i just ask uh
mr kane a couple of questions absolutely
all right so um been here a long time
but i've never
seen a nullification of prior
legislation so
this is rather uncommon is that correct
it's um since i've been here it's
uncommon it has occurred a few times
when you do have when house bill 2 is
typically
when you will see it where you'll have a
bill that's passed
and um there is a conflict that the
committee is made aware of
uh this is this i've probably seen this
a handful of times but it's not the
regular
way to do it all right so just so i'm
really clear
hb2 would nullify senate bill 85 the
broadband initiative
but if hb2 were not enacted into law
senate bill 85 would that has been
correct
that would proceed as its own path yes
correct so either way it
either nullifies and in
hb2 or it's not touched
that's correct okay okay
all right i'll move the amendment
senator bradley moves amendment
2021-1969-h
and represent weiler seconds
if the house is in favor of adopting
this please raise your hand
the senate we're unanimous on that
mr cain i think we were waiting for an
amendment on the sununu center
yes amendment 19 uh 2021 199918 we will
hand out
this amendment refers to sections 326
through 330.
represent weiler are you or
representative edwards going to speak to
this
if representative edwards is prepared
representative weiler moves the adoption
of 2021-199
h1 but why don't we hear the
because i think this is enough change we
may have to hold and think on this
overnight
uh madam chair i i agree with you um
and i i i do think it's possible that um
there's still an opportunity for
wordsmithing
uh is here but uh but this is uh this is
represents
um i think a good faith effort
to do a high bred piece of uh
legislation
around the idea that we uh both chambers
have committed
to closing the sununu center in this
budget um and so we
with this hybrid a key thing that we've
started out with is
reintroducing the hb 254 language
to reduce the
[Music]
the number of potential candidates there
might be for incarceration
by reducing those the numbers of those
being incarcerated
that is obviously thought to be
beneficial to
the youth involved but will also serve a
logistical advantage of just having
fewer people to worry about
transitioning so so you'll see on page
one
and then on page two and uh bold
highlights
the um the reintroduction of uh
components of hb 254.
we've added um some language to
allow some flexibility though if the if
there's still the possibility that uh
youth may represent a threat to society
uh this by is indicated by a substantial
risk of harm to others
um that it can go before court
where the judge can do an evidentiary
hearing
and get specific case findings relative
to
that child's or that that
juvenile's threat status
and make a determination if that
individual should be committed or
incarcerated
uh on the next page page four
uh uh we've accepted the senate budget
numbers
uh and and terms so so
the you'll see a lot of familiar stuff
in there
on page four
uh down around lines 29 or so
what we've done is we've said it's line
24 actually the that we've we
we would like you to consider a closure
date of 1 october uh 2022.
uh you uh had the senate had determined
that
um that march of 2023 would be
appropriate to give plenty of time for
the planning and execution
what the concern there was is that
we really want to make sure that
everyone is committed
to closing the sununu center and that
we're not
postponing actions critical actions
until the next legislature's in session
uh in other words you know this this
this is the time we are the people let's
get it closed
so we we're recommending one october um
the the number five beds do you have a
question senator bradley or do you
okay um so
on line 31
we have um inserted the number of five
beds
uh 18 beds had been floated you know i'm
i i don't think anyone can predict
exactly what the number ought to be
if if the senate were to come back with
a different number i wouldn't be
surprised we
then at the bottom of that page prohibit
any external funds being used by the
joint fiscal committee to
continue the operation of the sununu
center
beyond its closure date there's a
prohibition on use of funds
we we do limit the use of funds though
to
weatherproofing and i don't see a
definition of weatherproofing i would i
would
think that that may include a more
generic set of
building and infrastructure maintenance
so that
it doesn't fall into such disrepair that
it becomes a negative asset but
but the term weatherproofing is is used
in the current version
uh on page five um
rounds line nine through eleven uh we've
we've established the committee um and
we've specifically intended to insert
the possibility that the committee would
come up with a repurposing
of the sununu center and and not
be locked into the idea that they have
to build a new facility
that's that's a relatively new set of
facilities out there
and given that we just want fewer kids
in there
there ought to be a way to do a
renovation and leverage that
asset so so we don't we don't we're not
requiring a repurposing but we're saying
that repurposing as a potential
committee outcome then
when we get down to lines
22 through 25
um i i i think we may want to
take a look at this language um you know
senator bradley i know
you're good at reading these things it
says
that the committee plans shall consider
the following
but then in the very next line it says
it shall be operated by the department
of health and human services
so if that's a consideration of a shall
that's one thing but if the shall
overcomes the consideration and it
becomes it must be operated by dhhs
i'm not sure how the lingual legal
language works there
but i i i don't want to forestall
or require a particular recommendation
to come from this committee they should
have
freedom of thought and flexibility and
recommendation i believe
and from there um
i i'll admit that i just got this
version
uh moments before it got handed out to
you so
at that point i've actually stopped
reading and i don't have an
analysis for you but in summary i i
i'd say i i i think we're i think we're
trying to
agree figure out how to agree with the
senate on this and just get it done
that's that's our goal thank you
representative edwards
mr kane i just got this amendment as it
was handed down
yes and representative edwards did a
good job of summarizing but he went from
page one to page four could you just for
my simple mind
run us through all the sections
including what we didn't because i
was listening to him i can't read and
listen at the same time
if you could please yes kevin would love
to oh kevin
okay kevin you're up
uh to be honest i'm not the best person
either to discuss the uh content of
these changes all i can tell you is that
broadly speaking they incorporate
uh house bill 254 which changes the
criteria for detention and commitment of
minors
but even then there are a few
modifications in here to the house bill
254 language but again i'm not the best
person to speak to that
where is house bill 254
so as you know madam chair 254's
language was incorporated in house bill
and was removed by the senate but where
is house bill 254
did we pass it it was retained by the
house it was retained by the house in
committee
uh yes actually it's retained in house
finance
okay in division three must have 254 is
that correct representative edward
okay well i'm still back too i don't
know what these sections say because i
and not all this is bolded so i don't
really know how much is new language and
how much is not
new language since i don't
haven't seen 254 ma'am yeah
sooner morse yeah well the senate would
like to discuss
what they have in the budget because i'm
not sure
we're that far off and the um i
i think when the senate received the
budget from the house
it basically was we fund year one and
nothing
nothing that's what we received okay so
when we received it we said well
we got to find a solution because you
can't just drop it
i know some people would like to see
that happen but there's realities out
here and i think you could probably go
out and talk to law enforcement
about the fact that there are some
realities about
you know the sununu center but the when
we decided to do this we put in
um this finding because we like the
house said
we don't want this to be decided by the
next legislature
so we basically said that
it needs to be closed by march 1st and
the replacement needs to be open by
march 1st
anyone that's looking at construction
realizes that that construction has to
start under this legislature
so we went one step further when we put
the committee together
we said they had to report to kenny by
november 1st
of this fall so that he could
if he had to propose language
that we take up in january if there were
to be a change to where we are today
18 is a good example um running it with
the department
is a good example but the reality of
where we were trying to get to
was how do we function in 22 and 23.
that's where we're trying to get to so
we agree with the house
that closure's going to happen there's
no one backing off on that
we agree that these five members will
work this summer
report to kenny and when they report
basically we figured if legislation was
needed in january
it would be this legislature that either
has to appropriate because remember
there's no money in here to build
anything or to repurpose the current
building which
i'm probably more in favor of that than
anything but i'm not sure
that you're going to get that support
from anybody in the public to be honest
with you
but there's a whole bunch of things that
are going to happen along the way
the senate was basically just picking up
the fact that
we don't have a way to function after
this budget year coming up
that's what we were doing um if we were
to go through this
and make things happen um quicker
i don't know what the proposal would be
but
i don't think it would break the center
tire to come back in january and say
take back the 9 million that we have in
here too because we got a solution
but i think we're beating a horse here
that we don't have to beat
because everybody's in agreement i mean
there is no way something's not going to
start next year under this legislature
and you know using 23 or october is the
date
i don't think it's physically possible
to have it open in october
if if we're building something um if
we're going to repurpose
maybe but i the reality is
this group of five needs to get together
and get going
i mean it's stated right in here it's
going to be closed and it's going to be
closed
under our guidelines so i'm not sure
what we're arguing about on this
um and i'm not sure we're not trying to
i agree with
representative edwards there's probably
things i want to change right now
so if that if that had to happen when we
that we can change things i i don't care
but the only change that the senate
won't accept is
that we're closing it okay i i tell you
what
let's go back to your very first
statement mr kane
maybe this will be more up your alley
can i ask you because senator moore
started with
i think we should run through the
senate's proposal on the sununu center
okay why don't we run through that a
section at a time
and we have representative edwards and
senator morris
who both know if it's in the senate if
it's in
this amendment we were just handed and
so we can start to identify where we
have
similar things based on the amendment
because i still haven't been through
pages
most of page one and all page two and
three because we zip right to page four
so tell me what page you're on and what
section you're going to start with for
sure let's see here i i would
madam chair if i could just address one
point that senator morris made
we could could i please understand
exactly what the differences are between
the two things you did not cover it
mr ripple does not want to cover it i
really would like to understand this
document we just passed out before we
discuss if you don't mind
sure uh senator raleigh stand up um i
senator bradley if i give you one minute
i have to give representative edwards
one minute and represent first one man i
have to be fair here and i really would
like to know what i have if you don't
mind
okay sure i'll be very quick um on page
274 on the side by side
the statement of findings between the
house and the senate house section 358
in
senate section 326 are identical
um you'll see on page 274 where the
senate had deleted some sections
of these sections related to the sununu
center and that takes you all the way up
to section
page 280 which is senate section 327
senate section 327 is the appropriation
for the operation of the sununu center
uh for the biennium so 10.4 million for
and 9.922 for 23 appropriated to hhs for
operation of the suny news center
and then the source of funds are
identified
in the amendment that was just passed
out um amendment 1991
h on page four of the amendments
section 334 is identical
to the uh senate so the same
appropriation amount
on the side-by-side section 328 is
relative to transfer of funds for the
operation of the sununu center
which states that notwithstanding rsa
916 a
and c prior approval of fiscal committee
shall be required for any transfer funds
required for the operation of the suny
new youth services center
um and the house is prohibiting that as
representative edwards
explained they'll the house on the
amendment
1991 h page 4
section 335
the house is allowing notwithstanding
916 a and c
from the effective date of this section
which is july 1st until the closure of
the sununu center
so not the entire biennium but through
october 1st 22
prior approval of fiscal the general
court shall be required
for any transfer of funds for the
operation at the center but on october
2nd uh 2022 their authority to transfer
ceases
okay so the house shortened the
authority to transfer this
based on the closure correct and then
the
committee let me just turn real quick
if we go to page on the side by side the
next section on page 281
uh section 329 is where the senate
states the general court finds the
sununu center
the paraphrasing shall be closed no
later than march 1st 2023
in the opening of a replacement facility
shall occur no later than march 1st 2023
what the um house is proposing
is that that date of the sununu center
be closed not on march by march 1st 2023
but
several months earlier on october 1st
so that's you know in the senate section
is a statement of purpose 330 is the
committee established
that is on the bottom of page 281 or the
beginning of 281
in its place i believe let me just look
on amendment 1991
h
on page five is where the committee is
established
both required to deal develop a plan for
the closure
and replacement of the student eu
services center
the house added on page 5 line 10
and to provide oversight of the
implementation of the plan
members of the committee on page 281 on
the side by side three members
of the house of representatives two
members of the senate
in addition to the members legislative
members of the committee they shall
seek input this is the senate proposal
from department of health and human
services officer child advocate
disabilities rights center national
alliance on mental illness
new futures and any other group
organization the committee deems
necessary
if we go back to page five on the
amendment in addition to the same
legislative members three members of the
house two members of the senate in
addition
to the legislative members they shall
seek input and expert advice it doesn't
name the actual groups or organizations
it's more of a broad
seek the advice of whoever they deem
will be helpful
um can i ask you to address
representative edwards
question which was first came up in 25
with the shall be operated by the
department of health and human services
but
25 26 30 33
35 36 all have shells in them
the interesting thing is the senate
version has several shells
is that the equivalent of must
yes so that's must that's what the
committee must do
correct okay all right please continue
um so if we look at the after the
establishment
of the committee on page 281 on roman
numeral four
committee shall develop a plan for the
closure and replacement of the sununu
services center
including cost estimates for the
construction and operation of a new
facility
so that is what the senate is requiring
the committee for the the representative
weiler representative edwards had gone
over the committee shell to develop a
plan for the closure and replacement
or repurposing of the sununu youth
services center
so instead of the closure and
replacement is maintained by the house
but they also add the repurposing of the
suny
youth service center um also including
cost effects for the construction and
operation of a new facility
uh which is an extension it's similar to
what the
senate had as far as the shells
the senate on page 281 shall be operated
by the department of health and human
services
shall be designed to meet the unique
needs of up to 18 youth
at a time shall accommodate requirements
to separate youth by gender treatment
needs corridor safety and security
and the facilities shall include three
separate residential spaces each
including the capacity of
six youth so there would be three
separate residential spaces six youth
apiece
and then various capacity to provide
services to meet medical physical and
behavioral health needs
uh space for 18 beds adequate space for
educational needs
indoor and outdoor recreation
nutritional needs
necessary elements are architecturally
secure and equipped
video surveillance is required in the
senate as well as the opening of the
facility
no later than march 1st 2023
it requires the committee the senate on
page 282
to prepare legislation relative to the
implementation of the plan
developed by the committee for the 22
legislative session so the session that
begins in january
the members and then it goes over how
they elect a chairperson
for the study committee and the final
report shall be issued
and prepared and presented to the senate
president senate clerk house clerk and
governor
and the speaker by november 1st 2021
and that would require fiscal committee
approval
if we go back to the house amendment on
row 25 like the senate it shall be
operated by the department of health and
human services
um separate or different from the senate
on line 26
it shall be designed to meet the unique
needs of up to five youth at a time
which is
uh representative edwards had explained
and it does go over the various
uh reasons why uh youth would be
detained or committed
to this facility it shall it does
requirement
separate youth by gender treatment needs
and other relevant factors
it does uh require like the senate three
separate residential spaces and
appropriate common spaces it does not
say
how many beds each one shall have
provide services as the senate does for
medical physical behavioral health
nutritional educational needs
indoor and outdoor recreation
architecturally secure as the senate
does the big difference on row 37 the
opening of
replacement facilities shall be no later
moving over to page six on the amendment
uh the committee shall also
uh will also prepare necessary
legislation for the 22
legislative session and then it goes
over how the chairperson of that
committee would be named which is
similar to
what the senate has a final report also
to be issued
on november 1st 2021 and require
joint fiscal approval as the senate does
require
thank you mr kane okay i know at least
four people have had their hands up
senator bradley senator moore senator
uh representative edwards and
representative irf welcome to the table
who wants to go first gentlemen you'll
wait
okay why don't you go next because
turn your mic on
your mind up and talk into it yes
is that laughing on if you press the red
one down it's locked and on
okay so i agree with
much of what uh senator morse was was
saying and senator edwards
um but i'll note that we've glossed over
the probably the most important
change to the senate version which was
a critical part of the house version
it's actually the first part of the
house version as well
and that's the 254 uh hb 254 which
essentially is now
in the start of this amendment and was
also in the start of the house
version and hb 254
is really the linchpin of the system
since this is what divides
and reduces the the headcount of
children that would need to go into
a system such as this so it changes
the offenses that permit incarceration
at the center it only incarcerates
serious violent offenders and utilize
the system of care
that we've all developed or been
developing with dhhs
for those convicted of lesser offenses
and
if you're looking so there's basically
several places where
serious def offenses are defined
hey this is now in the amendment page
two
in bold lays down
a whole series of offenses um
currently even there are even some
misdemeanor offenses for which you can
be incarcerated
at the sununu center as well as a number
of other lesser offenses not less than a
misdemeanor but lesser than
very serious offenses that get you
incarcerated there
so and there's more there's more to that
i won't go into all the details of that
but there's a
whole series i mean so basically that is
the first one two
three
and almost a half pages that outlines
the the process by which we're going to
limit the number of
children that judges can have the option
to
incarcerate there however because we are
making some dramatic changes to the
specific offenses
we also as representative edwards
mentioned and this is in
the section j starting on line 28 of
page two
we do allow an out for a judge through a
hearing a full hearing full evidentiary
hearing
to make an exception so that somebody
that's
that doesn't qualify under the offenses
but that a judge feels
is appropriate to a center such as
restrictions such as sununu
could go ahead with that so
that's the 254 replacement and that is a
big part of the improvement to the
overall system since it reduces
the head count and allows for a smaller
facility
on the one hand on the other hand going
to the system of care i think this was
mentioned earlier by i believe as
representative over pointed out
that the senate appropriate
approximately 40 million dollars
for the behavioral youth pro
system of care program which essentially
is this
the intense ni from what i also
understand dhhs is already in the
process of
letting contracts for these systems
which involve intensive care with the
action say care
intensive handling of individual youth
with their family
over a three to six month period and all
that
funding and all that setup in my opinion
is intended to handle exactly this kind
of situation so you have these children
that are not the murderers that can't be
helped but rather the kids that we
really hope we can
reform and bring back into uh
society um so that's that's critical to
on the one hand it saves us money
because we can
they can federal match those with
children on the other hand it helps the
children which is really what this is
all about
um okay so let me just look at my nose
i'm sorry not to
can i ask the senate a question while
you're looking of course ma'am
okay as i understand this house bill 254
must have been a second committee bill
to house financial went directly to
division three without a
public hearing in-house finance and has
been retained
that means it went through probably
children and family law chaired by
representative rice has the senate
had an opportunity to have
a public hearing on these provisions
that represent earth was talking about
found on page two that are bold or is
this
language that you guys haven't worked on
at all i don't know where we are
um so um you're right madam chair
this bill to go through children and
family law
uh the vote was 14-1 and then it was
retained in committee um i
find that i i'm
not necessarily opposed to the changes
that
uh representative earth just outlined
i've
long been a supporter i think i was a
co-sponsor
of the system of care bill in
the last session it
is the way to go there is no question
about that in my mind
we're looking at it um as if it's all
going to be
smooth and no problem and
that we just adjudicate
the most serious youth offenses in these
changes
under house bill 254 we've been down
this
road before unfortunately several years
ago with efforts for
bail reform and i think
that having gone through that and having
seen people that should have been
retained in custody who are a danger to
themselves or a danger to society
and being released and
reoffending in a violent way
concerns me mightily with the provisions
in this bill
that may well be good but need
certainly more scrutiny by our side
um because it never they never did have
a hearing in the
in the judiciary committee and senator
carson who i would note i believe was
the sponsor of
254. having said that
we're in agreement that the sununu
center should be closed
okay we have a slightly different
approach than
you folks do a little bit more time and
a little bit more flexibility in terms
of the number
of kids but i i would go back to when we
first
i think it was in the 2017 budget when
senator carson and i were tasked with
working with you folks and division
three
on um changes to the sununu center
the attendance was 70 kids roughly if i
remember
and now the average attendance is about
12. so we've made
remarkable changes but i want to know
before we make the changes
in 254 that the system of care is up and
operable
that it's diverting the misdemeanor
type offenses that you listed that
should be diverted into the system of
care
that they're not going from misdemeanor
level offenses to violent offenses
that we don't have you know an outbreak
of
youth crime that we have no um
opportunity to curtail because these
things are now
in law and having been burned by bail
reform
i i just you know plead
let's be cautious let's be careful let's
do it right
know that we have to close the sununu
center but one of the reasons
that i advocated for the additional time
was so that there was full opportunity
to discuss the
changes that are being proposed here and
make sure we get it right
we didn't get it right in my opinion on
bail reform and we're paying a price for
it
and god help us if
you know some of the violent activity
that we've seen in new hampshire from
people that got
pr bail now become youth being released
because we can't detain them
i find that to be problematic so i think
you know we need to work on this
work on it carefully and speed is not
always the best issue
when trying to work on it carefully so
thank you madam chair
okay i think what we ought to do here
and i think
representative edwards said that when
you get something you think about
could be some wordsmithing i think we
ought to get our comments out here on
the table
so we all hear them and then we're going
to hold this
until we meet tomorrow rather than do it
now so we have a con
think about what do you think about this
what do you think about that
where do they mesh together so who else
would
represent i'm sorry senator rosenwald
followed by senator morse
thank you um i'm just
looking at the department's
monthly dashboard and for
every month of this fiscal year
we've had no more than seven
committed youth at
this sununu center we've had somewhere
between
four and ten detained youth
even with a broader allowance for what
kinds of
charges can get someone
so personally i think a smaller
facility is reasonable i don't know five
is
right but probably smaller
but the other thing i would just mention
that in the
the fiscal year 23 appropriation that's
in both the senate version and this
amendment
was based on the sununu center
operating for eight months of fiscal
year 23
and the house you're talking about three
months
so um maybe
we could play around with that
maybe there'd be some money for
construction out of this
9.9 million it could be soon remorse
followed by
representative edwards i just i just
want to point out a few things one
um on page 279 there's an appropriation
from the house that's certainly
considered
you know you close it at the end of 22
budget
you still have all of 23 that you have
to deal with issues so you were
considering that anyways in the house
phase
so having said that i can see where
if you take the senate's version and you
go to page
159 if you go down to line
the committee shall develop a plan for
closure replacement of the
new youth services center the house's
language
the committee shall develop a plan for
the closure and placement or repurposing
of the similar youth center
including cost estimates for
construction and operation
of the new facility the committee's plan
shall consider the following
that language i think meets what all of
us are trying to do
much better so i think the senate if
you're drafting something tonight
would be amenable to that
there was also language on page 160
the committee shall issue the final
report
if you go to page six
of the amendment that's being suggested
um line number one
of what's being suggested the committee
shall prepare necessary legislation
relative to implementation
of the plan developed in paragraph four
for the 22 legislative session i don't
think that's anything different than
what i explained when i first got here
so including that in here would be fine
taking a step in reverse i think it's
the house that's
suggested a couple of times in the last
two days
that if the legislation didn't go
through your committee
then it should be taken up next year
we'd probably suggest the same thing on
this legislation
because we haven't taken up that bill
but if we could put those two amendments
in here i think it gets to
where everybody's trying to get to and i
guess my point about march first was
we were trying to do the same thing you
were trying to do not let it get
into another legislature so i just don't
think
you're going to get it done before march
1st but
october won't work maybe january 1 works
i don't know
but the reality is
that committee that meets the summer
could do a lot of the work if we follow
what i just said
and get it to us in fiscal in november
first and then get it to legislation in
january
isn't that the point of everything we're
trying to do
representative edwards you also want to
speak it's become
overcome by events representative morris
has recognized
excuse me senator morris has recognized
that in the second year
our appropriations were in hb2 there
were three sections there with
appropriations to
handle the closure we put it into hb2
because we thought those were one-time
expenses and not
the operating side so it's just a
different approach
and and we i your numbers are are good
we can go with your numbers
i think if we could make those two
changes to be honest with you because we
agree with you
that the committee's gonna here's the
guidelines
we want you to come with legislation in
january
you have to report out november i think
those are
two amendments the senate could accept
from your language
so so division three has uh on this
issue
uh we've been led uh by representative
weiler
and uh representative walner if they
have uh comments i
i i like what you're saying but uh i'd
like to get them involved if we can
madam chair representative walner i know
that representative erful
yield a chair to you if you'd like to
step up to make some comments
i think we're trying to move to a place
where we could get an amendment
and try to get something done tomorrow
so
working on this together is the way to
go
while she's moving up my one concern
both the senate and the house want to
have three separate areas
i don't know how you divide five beds
into three separate areas
but i'm just because i have a simple
mind with simple math i can do six and
two bits in each of the three areas gets
me to six
but it's just me okay
representative walner representative
um thank you uh representative ober
um i guess on the number i think
would be interesting to talk with the
senate for us to talk me with the senate
about coming together
on a number that seems to work um i
would
be more than willing to to have that
conversation
i do think that 254 is really
important um and i also think that
allowing for the judicial override that
we've included in
the house amendment makes a lot of sense
so that if there is a child
that um does not fit within the 254
guidelines but does need that level of
care
that the opportunity would be there for
a judge to have
that child incarcerated at the new
at the new facility and that's
really where i am um thank you
thank you madam chair uh i'd be happy to
make the changes that uh
senator morris mentioned just you said
two changes go over them briefly again
please so
i'll be ready to make the changes i
think just so that
the chair realizes the house
language allows you to change the number
of beds to whatever because the house
language says the committee
shall develop a plan for closure and
replacement
or repurposing of the sununu youth
center including cost
estimates for construction and operation
of a new facility
the committee's plan shall consider
so you you basically left you can drive
a freight train through that one
and then the other language that i would
put at the end
is the committee shall report shall
prepare necessary legislation relative
to the implementation of the plan
developed i think we're all in agreement
on that
i i so i don't think it stifles anything
except for like 254
in the sense that the senate's just
asking for the same thing the house has
been asking for all day
that we put that through a committee and
i'm sure it's going to get fast-tracked
because
and and fast-tracked i mean everybody in
the audience is going to have to learn
to agree that whatever
senate in the house comes because they
all have different opinions
so i think the fact is the senate's
on the same course as the house that we
want to get something done here
so i don't think that's the problem um
and for the purple people that wanted to
close this place
we agree but we just got to figure out a
way to operate
did you want me to tighten up the
language of what the committee can
suggest or i thought adding your two
pieces are fine
okay yeah i think you add it to what
exists right now
and yeah it gets to where you guys want
to get to um
if we can get it done earlier i'm sure
this committee of five can figure that
out
we will so i think i heard you say
senator morris that
the senate would like to for the purpose
of this amendment moving forward in hb2
remove the
the pieces that chan that are in
house bill 254 that deal with the legal
changes do i have that right not sure i
think
you'd be making a mistake trying to
do it that way i think you could
instruct lba
to take what's in the budget right now
and put the house's positions
two areas into the budget
and the senate would accept those
friendly amendments
mr cain does that make wonderful sense
to you
since you're the lba and you will be
directing the work on that
yes and so we would be making an
amendment to the current senate sections
as they exist in house bill 2 to include
the repurposing provision as well as the
um shall consider provision that kind of
leaves it open to the committee
to the house members who are working on
this
we have representative edwards walner
and wyler
are you understanding what he just said
so we're in agreement so we get one
amendment and it's right tomorrow
that's where i'm trying to go i want to
get this done i want everybody to be
happy
if possible representative edwards
a small comment a large yes
i i understand i support what you're
doing with the
senator morris i would just point out
that on
page five line 25
if you start to bring that language over
mr kane
um it's got a another shall
where the word may on uh
line 25 ought to be so that there's no
con
confusion between what our shallows and
our considerations
that's why i said earlier represent
walnut where are you
i've been looking to the three of you i
well i i still think that 254
is what makes this work or not work
um
i guess i i need more time to to really
think however
the division three has retained 254.
you could work on that piece fast track
it out in january to the senate
right am i correct you've retained that
right
we've retained that and i i i i i if
somebody were more creative and we could
add it to
the calendar on the 24th if we could
vote it out of the house and
give it to the senate is that yeah i've
talked to the speaker i think we would
take two-thirds vote to change the rules
or something all right
i'm just thinking i'm not sure
most of it's right in this amendment
i i think out of courtesy though i mean
the senate's not going to consider that
position in the budget
that's that's doing something far beyond
where we are today in the budget
i don't understand which position you
use the 254 which is the language you
put in your amendment up front okay um
i i just out of courtesy i think
we go into january and have that debate
so so i understand your position center
more so
you've not had a chance to hear it it
makes a radical change to policy
your committee needs to hear it and
we've kept it in the house even though
we've passed it
it makes sense senator rosenwald
thank you i just i'm a little confused
because it seems like the senate
position
has been up to 18 children
closed on march 1st and we'd be putting
in this committee
that's calling for a facility of five
no we would that's open on october 1st
we take the senate language that exists
today
and we give them what the house has
asked for
that these are just guidelines they're
not what you have to do
so if the five-member committee meets
and the five-minute
member committee decides that just in
the best interest of the state to
develop
five coincidental then that's what we'd
be doing
i i we're not restricting the committee
from doing
anything um i suppose they ought to know
eighteen's as big as anyone
would accept but um
you know there's a lot going on here i
i think i i've been working through this
with people like skivy since 2011 when i
got back here
so for us to get to where we are today
this is a home run to close the place
so i i think we're okay we're debating
and you're gonna step away but you can
live with that
okay yes thank you for coming forward
all right mr kane i think we have
actually
arrived at a an agreement
between the house and the senate on
another amendment that will be a hybrid
of both bodies work
and you can make that happen kevin um
we'll look at these changes uh we'll
also send
oh okay um we'll come up with a draft
amendment to share with
all of you just to ensure that we're
moving in the right direction
okay excellent
i have another question on another topic
mr kane
page 273 senate pass section 325
we were going to get an amendment oh no
we acceded to the house version didn't
do we have any other amendments that we
have not
dealt with that are of new amendments i
know we've had a couple of new
amendments as we've gone along
okay mr king we've gone to page one of
our
summaries side by side comparison
and basically we have section 16 and 16
a senate pass the senate is going to
exceed to the house is that correct
gentlemen
and lady they do it quietly yes they can
do it quietly
okay
senate section 297 to 300.
and i think we've reached a point where
we've done what we can
today
in which case is it agreeable to
everyone to reconvene
at one o'clock tomorrow afternoon
yes
okay earlier if you want no we don't
know if we'll be ready
represent go ahead
no i i'm gonna bring it up because the
senate
is not gonna proceed to any position on
the community college system in the
university system
we've uh had this discussion for a month
now
and i i can't see the senate
looking at anything we're just gonna
make that happen
before january when we file legislation
to
move forward with something but
okay i there that leaves
probably two or three major issues
between the senate and the house
that i think we have to come back on
tomorrow
um committee meeting on 417
family leave act that we need to talk
about
where if if you look at the summary
side-by-side comparison on page five
we're looking at house pass sections 117
119. i know representative umberger has
already been talking about
filing legislation for that in the fall
the senate did not put anything in there
it's on hold
and they will not exceed is the house
ready to accede to
okay representative umberger moves to
exceed to the remo
to agreeing with the center on sections
117 through 119
representative weiler the house if
you're in favor could you please raise
we're opposed four to one
the senate mister
you have exceeded so we have acceded to
their position mr cain that allows you
to close those off we still have
a couple of open issues and
as senator moore said we would like to
put
417 which is how undergoing a committee
conference
into hb2 they're still working on it so
we don't have that
language it's not something we can even
discuss today senator morris
no but i would like to speak to that
because
i i want to be clear i i have worked
with house members the governor
and one senate member that
has tried to find agreement on
the issues in 417. i've served in this
body now
for almost 20 years
and compromise is the only way we're
going to get things i will not vote
tomorrow
to put in the budget anything the
governor won't accept
so i want to make it clear that the
senate's not headed there
so if there's something that can come
tonight
or tomorrow morning from the 417
committee
that the governor will accept i'll
support it
but i am not going to put something when
there's
basically three bodies to get to speak
in the budget um that we can't agree on
because that's just not the right way to
do it let them send 417 to the
governor's desk
and if the language doesn't work for the
governor he can veto it
i was all along it was my goal to put it
in the budget
they are now facing two amendments one
that's acceptable to the governor
and one that he's made clear isn't
acceptable
this has been a challenging time in the
state of new hampshire i probably
debated the governor more than anyone in
this room
on how we've handled things in the state
of new hampshire but he's the governor
and the reality is when we were done
i worked with him and i don't think we
should do anything different
in closing this budget and we never have
by the way
because since the day i was put on as
finance chair which was the first time
that i ever served on a finance
committee
till today that i sat on a finance
i said to lynn ober i was in there with
kirk more times than we've ever been
this time and we were slamming heads
until 12 o'clock at night
to get an agreement between all the
bodies and
we always did it so to walk away from
getting an agreement between
everyone is the wrong answer in my
opinion
i'll be back here tomorrow at one
o'clock it's
certainly going to be something that
i'll go watch tomorrow morning
at the committee level because i believe
that's when 417 is meeting but
whether or not it goes in the budget it
has to be acceptable to the speaker the
senate president
and our bodies and also to the governor
and i i won't vote to do anything
different
and i will tell you we have not been
beating heads together
the house and the senate were in
agreement on more
in hb2 this time than i have ever seen
we work very closely together we're
going to continue to do that mr kane i
think i've made another mistake
if you turn to page five of that
side-by-side comparison i think when we
did
sections 117 118 119
i should have included 120 is that
correct
uh yes we assumed you included in that
sense of reference doing that for me
since i didn't say it
covering up for me as always i
appreciate it mr kane
all right we are now going to be
in recess until one o'clock tomorrow
afternoon
once again i'd like to thank the work of
the village that supports us behind the
scenes we couldn't get where we are
without all the work with ols we don't
ever see them
and lba the chief of staff the assistant
chief of staff the governor's budget
director has been here
lisa english has been sitting with us
for a couple of days we couldn't have
gotten along without her
so we appreciate everybody coming it's
been nice seeing faces again
and we will be back at one o'clock
tomorrow afternoon
you